[Music]
y'all know that Takashi 69 6-9 year
don't takashi he's the he's the rapper
with the snowcone hair and he looks like
this
you guys know mr. Takashi I didn't know
he was caught Takashi I just knew the
six nine it was spelled all weird
yeah my generation loves him we're big
fans yes actually he came out with a new
song but that's not what we're talking
about here today he was uh well it was
that and he's gone on right he went on
Instagram she was live streaming guess
how many people were watching that [ __ ]
1 million - oh I saw your mouth though
oh my god we're just [ __ ] love the
drama I would probably be honest just to
see the dumb [ __ ] that he's about to say
and he did say some dumb ass [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] so um you know you got you went to
prison right mm-hmm
no but he got his charges ok so yeah he
went to prison for some charges drug
group right like they had a bunch of
racketeering case he's a part of a gang
called the ninth ray Bloods and it was a
whole RICO conspiracy thing tray like
Sosa 93 okay
you only like sleaze no idea tray lunch
tray okay racketeering and Rico yeah
what's Rico Rico is like when you do a
conspiracy case and Riaan Rico just
sounds tight yeah in summary when you
get caught on Rico they prosecute
everybody in the game from the leader
all the way to the bottom bottom [ __ ]
even associate what's racketeering
racketeering is crime laundering and
like drugs but it's like all together
it's such a better way to say those
things to me forever to explain what
well you try to get someone killed
well there's all kinds of [ __ ] I don't
really know the details so I'm gonna
[ __ ] try to pretend but what happened
the main part here is to get a lesser
sentence
homeboy ratted which is a very very bad
thing to do you don't rat on your game
you win pants I am wearing shorts 14
style bro
I know shoes [ __ ] yes looks good
thank you professional casual yes I'm a
bunny [ __ ] master alright so here's
the thing
he came on Instagram to set the [ __ ]
record straight oh it wasn't a rack that
was [ __ ] put up so actually admitting
that he's a rat and he goes record is
straight then everybody knows I saw it
running till I saw we talked about so I
didn't see I was on in life I saw it the
video after and it made sense what do
you say it is it is and this is the most
gems II [ __ ] I've ever seen right a
gangster rapper goes on Instagram and he
does a poll to see this question right
he goes if they kidnap you and stole you
from and I stole from you slept with
your baby moms threatened your mom stole
millions from you cut on the phone
trying to kill you would you switch
snitch or go do jail time and you did a
[ __ ] pool well I mean just taking
that thing in the context that [ __ ] my
snitch to never [ __ ] it's me I would cuz
I'm not in a gang I don't live by that
other people were like if you're not in
a gang don't you have no say in all of
this [ __ ] rat dude excuses guys from
looking gang talked about it oh yes yep
well I'd say if one violates the rules
of loyalty then all hell breaks loose do
whatever you want if he is true and then
and this is what happened let's say that
they were like [ __ ] his baby mama
they were stealing millions from him
because apparently in this whole thing
she was saying man I help these guys out
there was sleeping on the couch I
[ __ ] help them they
I paid for their school their kids
[ __ ] school all that and and all
their city to [ __ ] my baby mama when I'm
in prison that just sounds so one-sided
though like I'm pretty sure they like he
got his [ __ ] fair share of muscle and
like a bunch of other [ __ ] from them too
is not that any of it is you should have
framed it better cuz I would never say
snitch I would say I got revenge would
you get revenge you don't say you Snider
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it sounds like a
[ __ ] and this is a music video he's
wearing a Joseph in a Technicolor
raincoat just the color raincoat the
sequel that's his music video right yeah
and that's an ankle bracelet right there
cuz he's on house yeah he wants street
cred dude our kids gonna try to wear
ankle bracelets now if they're pretty
cool they look pretty cool you know he
lived neck so they relocated him to like
a safe house and a fan lived next door
it was like yo like just trying to be
like all those look it's crazy who lives
next door and here to move how do you
have to paint him as a yeah like how do
you relocate but the point of it is that
they just disappear off the Nate like
off the plan yeah but he's got all those
tattoos and [ __ ] you can't [ __ ] put
this guy in a price even cut his hair
off or something are you like well I
think where they relocate people they
don't like if you're supposed to be
famous they can't put you anywhere you
just have to stay at home I'm gonna
[ __ ] kangaroo costume yeah I don't
know if he's on under witness protection
or I don't know yeah I don't know yeah I
think they're just moving him and he
can't be in the same city but he's got
some new jewelry though you see it's the
it's the shark it's from Finding Nemo
that's very sick yeah it's very gangster
yeah yeah is he like I love that movie
there was a baby or five years ago right
and that crazy [ __ ] crazy
his fenced in a two million fans were
they like hell yeah you did the right
thing
people were like oh that makes sense
yeah they were cited well not hiding but
how did the pool end up I didn't see the
pole I wish I knew the results of the
poll but that's the pole here then
snitch or Jesus snitch [ __ ] man [ __ ]
[ __ ] get revenge he sounds like revenge
if I live by that code I will just went
and killed them exactly me a [ __ ]
thug that's you don't [ __ ] work with
the feds you never do yeah and then say
how they [ __ ] dick you over this hole
- I don't know a person if someone just
do that to me alpha class there's day 1
course this badass anyway like it's not
like I'm like oh yeah you know what I do
I'd sit with the feds and I have a bomb
strapped to my chest
you stole my last drink what is it if
you stole my last drink I would snitch
on you see exactly I think most of us
would rock and roll on each other
immediately
I wouldn't go it in nah dude out if you
guys killed some also live by the
gangster life yeah but I never killed
somebody I'm a wannabe well I said we're
not even friends and you would snitch on
me right away well that's just you oh
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
no man if you if you guys accidentally
killed somebody and you called me over I
will help you get rid of the body a
hundred percent that's if you didn't
wrong at me I win snitch huh if like if
the person didn't wronged me in any way
yeah I live by the bro code that's a
true Vietnamese right there I don't know
if someone did something they were like
if they're like a close friend I was
like I'll just tell him to go deal with
Tonno don't get me involved I'm not
saying anything hear anything but if you
start getting me involved but now I
could go down with you because you're an
idiot even though you're my friend
you're gonna have to kill the idiot now
that one of those things oh damn well
the cop combo yeah you did I got a
scenario for you are you ready for some
gangster twilight zone don't tell me
[ __ ] oh hell yeah gangster twilight zone
is this Joe you get called a mil a night
one of your close friends like yo you
got to help me this is a body there you
help them with the body you guys take it
up the mountains and all the [ __ ] when
you get there while you're taking the
body out you realize it was your mom oh
[ __ ] wait is there a question it took
too long what do you do
worried is that the question well
point.i i would fear my life because if
it was my mom and they're calling me
then they're trying to kill me than a
message oh [ __ ] and that's really that's
what I would say so as soon as I
recognized that no questions asked I'm
murdering that person okay
Ernest well I was it you when you when
you the guy was like hey we gotta give
her this body and this one's a Twilight
Zone you gotta take the body up you dig
the grave you open the bag to put the
body in the grave it's you then I
thought I think I'm dead and I'll go
ghosts would you say all your friends
what that point or what would you do I
don't know why did you call me to see my
dad damn that I don't even know what to
do that's crazy that's fair how were you
able to dig the hole to begin with if
you're in the bag that's why this should
get your Toyota you have to go back and
solve your own death that's pretty good
cuz this is [ __ ] that's not even that
smart or interesting or good but
somebody out there like so I got I got
another question for you guys though so
six nine right he donated 200 grand to
charity it was like some what is this no
Kid Hungry campaign so as to feed [ __ ]
kids right oh they refused it well I
said we don't take money from your kind
dirty money oh they have to only take
money from donator from donations make
money from people that we don't also see
it with like we wouldn't along with your
value you have to align with the values
I would have taken the [ __ ] money cuz
what's more important to me is hungry
kids I'll be like I'm gonna let them
starve
well they're I think their company or
their organization's about like working
with kids and I don't think they want to
send a message to kids to be like well
how would they know this guy's right
look at all the money he has how we're
working with each other the kids just
[ __ ] I'm not gonna eat it
well I mean like he promoted as like I'm
working with
and then they could associate the two
together oh yeah yeah unless they were
scared that the money's coming from like
illegal means and they're like it's
probably gonna get I think outside of
the kids who the parents would be
concerned what you have to get concerned
very here it's fault because they can't
feed the kids anyway so but drug dealers
gonna [ __ ] pay for their meal let
that [ __ ] roll yeah it's a great
message to the public that we the
parents can be friendly to yeah yeah
let's look at the positive side even
though this guy has a hair color of a
[ __ ] cotton candy in a candy store he
came up out of the hood
Diddy though I don't know but he said
it's he's never seen something so cruel
and that says a lot from a gangster
there's a lot from a gangster who looks
like he escaped the wonka factory he
caught he said that's funny he said that
they had sex with his wife and that the
whatever he listed is not even that
cruel for a gangster this is he's never
seen anything this cruel to refuse the
donation so he's not oh yeah yeah that's
what he said he's like he's never seen
something so he's really heartbroken it
snow flake gangster yeah he's really
heart broke it was so cruel yeah he's
gonna write a song about that they
didn't take my donation I like this guy
I gangsta with feelings finally true
whoo what are the kids gonna be breaking
barriers yeah man everything was too
hard for too long now it's time to go a
little softer I like it
[Music]